[Music]
what I have to say to you ye Norman's
the bravest of Nations does not spring
from any doubt of your valor or
uncertainty of victory which never by
any chance or obstacle escaped your
efforts if indeed once only you had
failed of conquering it might be
necessary to enflame your courage by
exhortation but how little does the
inherent spirit of your race require to
be roused most valiant of man what
availed the power of the Frank King with
all his people from Lorraine to Spain
against Hastings my predecessor what he
wanted of the territory of France he
appropriated to himself only what he
chose was left to the king what he had
he held during his pleasure when he was
satisfied he relinquished it and looked
for something better did not Rollo my
ancestor the founder of our nation with
your progenitors conquer at Paris the
king of the Franks in the heart of his
dominions nor could he obtain any
respite until he humbly offered
possession of the country which from you
is called Normandy with the hand of his
daughter did not your father's take
prisoner the king of the French and
detained him a true war until he
restored Normandy to your Duke Richard
with this stipulation that in every
conference between the King of France
and the Duke of Normandy the Duke should
have his sword by his side while the
king should not be allowed so much as a
dagger
this concession to your father's
compelled the Great King to submit to as
binding forever did not the same Duke
lead your father's to murmur at the foot
of the Alps and enforce submission from
the Lord of the town his son-in-law to
his own wife the Duke's daughter nor was
it enough to conquer mortals for he
overcame the devil himself with whom he
wrestled and cast down and bound him
leaving him in a shameful spectacle to
angels but why do I go back to former
times when you in our time engaged the
French at Mortimer did not the French
prefer flight to battle and use their
Spurs instead of their swords while
Ralph the French commander being slain
you reaped the fruits of victory the
honor and the spoil as natural results
of your wanted success let any one of
the English whom our predecessors both
Danes and Norwegians have defeated in
our hundred battles come forth and show
that the race of Rollo ever suffered a
defeat from his time until now and I
will submit and retreat is it not
shameful then that a people are customed
to be conquered a people ignorant of the
art of war a people not even in
possession of arrows should make a show
of being arrayed in order of battle
against you most valiant is it not a
shame that this King Harold perjured as
he was in your presence should dare to
show his face
to you it is a wonder to me that you've
been allowed to see those who by a
horrible crime but headed your relations
and Alfred my kinsmen and that their own
curse heed heads are still on their
shoulders raise then your standards my
brave men and set no bounds to your
merited rage let the lightning of your
glory flash and the thunders of your
unset be heard from east to west and be
the Avengers of the noble blood which
has been spilled
you